ううっうぅうううおおおおおお
今から日本語の講座を行います
を同源何してるをマイケル今免許更新をしてきた
アメリカと比べて超楽だったんそうなんうん初日は目の検査と写真撮影で2日目も短い
悲劇映画を2本見るだけ
しかも全部近くの警察署で出来るから運転
免許センターに行く必要がないだから待つ時間も交通時間も含めても全部3時間以内で
終わった
超簡単でしょちなみに同源って何州だったっけ
ワシントン種なんでそこなる今は免許更新はネットで出来るよ
ところで新しいスターウォーズを見たいや面白かったけど僕の中でやっぱ帝国の逆
ん
いらっしゃいませざいませんいロッソ言ういるソンモ
そういうモス西洋雷をなぜ
んいらっしゃいません sao
はいウェルカムです
いっ
許氏今年こそ男らしくなるんだ
筋トレ再開でどうしようかなぁ近くにちゃんとしたジムがないからまずは家で筋トレが
できるように
すかっトラックとお守りを買おうか最近運動してないから60キロで十分だ
んカシーナどの
に専門20キロの重りがない10キロの家ついを使えばいいか
なれば20キロのバーベルだっけが必要か
うん
20キロのバーベルもなええっ
本当にどこにも多いんだんジムもないしお守りも買えない
みんなどうやって筋トレしてんだろう
草食系男子
なにこれ
警告ラベル警告などは今から警告ラベルを読みます
注意この警告ラベルには注意自己が5つあります
1この警告ラベルの内容を読み間違えないように気を付けて下さい
に吐き気がする場合は15府の休憩をしてからまた最初からいい
見直すこと3個の警告ラベルを子供の手の届かないところに保管しなさい
4恐れがあります
ぼ
念のため1から4までもう1回読んで下さい注意
上記の内容にご不明の点があれば下記のサポートセンターに電話してください
注意掛け間違いをしないように気を付けて下さい
ni